So today I want to talk to you a bit about the new feature that we've recently added to Burp Suite
Intruder to allow you to attack multiple hosts within the same attack configuration. So previously
with Intruder to define your attack target you had to specify a host name, a port, and whether
or not you wanted to use HTTPS or not. Now that was great if you wanted to attack a specific target
with an attack configuration, but if you then wanted to do a bit more of a reconnaissance style
approach and use the same configuration against multiple targets it was quite a manual and laborious
process to go through and either duplicate the attack itself or the config and manually change
the target configuration. So to remedy this we've now removed the target tab and replaced it with
the target panel which provides a template for you to automatically inject payloads into your target
field to dynamically change the target as your attack progresses. So we're going to jump into an example
with Burp Suite to show you exactly how this works. So here I'm running a version of Burp Suite Pro which
is 2021.12 on the early adopter channel and I'm going to populate an attack configuration with an
intruder using a just a simple request get request to portswiggalabs.net and for those of you don't know this
is quite a good way to populate a quick request within intruder. So for this example I'm going to be
enumerating subdomains of portswiggalabs to try and find any hidden access points that shouldn't be available to the public,
like some kind of administrator or staff page. So to do this we can see that with this new target panel
we've now got an input field where we can specify a template. So I'm going to specify just a dummy
x subdomain and I'm going to wrap that x value with a set of payload markers. Now what this will allow me
to do is to use a payload source to automatically provide values into the target tab. So the target will
change throughout the course of this attack. So if I go to the payloads tab we're going to have just
one simple list payload because we're using a sniper attack type. I don't want another tab. Thank you.
And I'm going to select a short list of directories from the pre-made lists that we get given in Burp
Street Professional. And finally to help me find any interesting responses I'm going to use the
grep match feature to search for specific attributes of a login page. So for example you might expect the
strings username or password to appear in those responses. So we'll match on simple string that's
fine. So I think we're all ready to go. So I'm going to start the attack. So as we're waiting for this
attack to finish some interesting new things about the about the results table. So we've now got this target
column. So if you have provided payload markers within your target template we will now automatically
show you this column and it essentially shows you what the target was that we sent to for this payload.
So for the access payload we've automatically replaced the x that was previously on that target
and we've now set issued this access this just get request to the root of access.portswiggalabs.net
Sist attack is finished so let's filter by our new columns and we can actually see that the staff
payload has hit some matches with our username and password grep match strings. So if we have a look at
the response of one of these other payloads we can see that it's just a generic kind of landing page.
So if we render that gives us a bit more of an idea of what that looks like. So it's just a kind of
landing page to say hello this is Portswiggalabs. But if we jump at the staff response we can see that
we're actually getting a login form. If we render we can see that we can provide a username and password
and try to gain access. So this has been a successful subdomain iteration attack to try and identify a
hidden input access point to gain access to the domain through using other methods. So from now we
could maybe try and brute force this form or if you've been able to retrieve credentials in another
way you could use it to try and gain access. So thanks for listening and I hope you enjoy the feature.